okay so here is our first lab um this is
this lab introduces some basic uh
Concepts in Python um Python's a very
popular programming language and and
many if any of you have taken any
programming classes prior to this class
uh in statistical learning you'll likely
have seen some python already um so
that's also a warning to say that this
is not a complete exhaustive
introduction to the language of python
there are lots of uh tutorials out there
uh for python we've included uh a link
um below for the the basic Python
tutorial and uh they we're also going to
be using several common packages pandas
and numpy and you can find tutorials for
those online as well um and and also the
text and everything you see on this page
is exactly what's in the in the lab in
the book yes and as I said this is the
one I downloaded just off the stat
learning um statistical learning website
okay so we're not going to read all the
text here sitting in the lab we're going
to go through just some of the code um
you can follow along in more detail by
running the labs as this is the code
that you have access to on the on the
website and is the code that's that's in
the
book okay
so let's start off with um some basic
objects in Python uh so there's as most
languages have different types of
objects um and for us we'll be
interested in in numeric objects but uh
python itself is a language that evolves
not to do data analysis but just as a
general purpose language in any case so
there are lots of different types
standard types of objects in Python
let's just start with um a string um and
this is an example of calling a function
almost everything we do in a in these
computer computations will be calling
some kind of function here's an example
we'll call the print function um okay
and this is an example you can see how
the Jupiter notebooks run there's a
little text box of code that is executed
um and the output of the code shows up
beneath you just pressed return I press
shift return for each cell yes um and
that will move run this run the code and
move it
down as in in lots of environments you
might have some questions about um you
know the functions you're using
there helps a help system in um in
Jupiter you can access help by putting a
question mark after the name of the
function and it will give you what's
called its dock string so if you have a
function where you're not sure exactly
what it does you can use this question
mark and many functions have very
helpful doc strings okay besides strings
there are of course
numbers numbers 3 plus three and five
add up to
eight and uh
you know surprisingly enough you can
also add other types of objects here we
can add strings and when we add strings
it is concatenation most of our work
will not be adding strings this is just
you know the typical hello world
introduction to to a
language so we've seen numbers we've
seen strings there are other objects in
Python that start to look like things we
might use in Computing that look start
to look like a vector so down here I've
got something that's called a list in
Python it's denoted by the square
bracket
and it's the number list of the numbers
three four and
five okay um and in doing calculations
you'll often want to add two of them so
let's make another list 49 and seven and
let's try adding them and there's some
counter counterintuitive results here um
because this illustrates in some sense
that uh you know python is not
necessarily doesn't do the perhaps the
most natural thing you'd think to do
with two list of numbers it concatenates
the list instead of adding them element
wise and that's well that's because
there's lots of different types of
objects in Python for data analysis what
we'll really want to use are arrays um
that is you know representations of
numbers in the computer and when we have
two vectors we'd expect we when we add
them the result should be the sum of the
vectors and for that we're going to use
this uh package numpy which is this the
uh the standard uh numerical library in
Python um okay
we we'll see some aspects of numpy in
this lab and here is a link to a a more
exhaustive tutorial or the quick start
with links to more in-depth tutorial if
you need so Jonathan lists can have
items of arbitary different types right
so that's why you can't just add right
because that's a great question you
couldn't add three to hello yes so
Trevor points out here that here my list
had numbers but actually we could have a
um a string in there as well
um and we could have other things as
well we could have U even the print is a
function we could add that to the list
and when we add it um you'll see it
concatenates x with this new list y so
that's uh lists are are just sequences
of any arbitrary python objects there's
another type of sequence we'll see in a
minute called a tle um that looks a lot
like a list but is slightly different
okay anyways this illustrates that
python has a lot of generic programming
functionality that really has nothing to
do with numerics and that's why we use
these libraries numpy and and for um
more structured data we use pandas the
that use so-called data
frames okay so we're going to use this
this package num numpy for numerical
python it's our first example of a
library that we'll use
and so library is just some other code
that's been added to the language or is
not let's say loaded into the into the
into the program when we start the
program so we have to access it and that
uses this this uh import statement so in
the further Labs we'll see that every
lab will start off with many of these
type of import statements this actually
is what tells the computer where to find
the code that we will use later when we
want to run these specific um functions
okay so once we have numpy loed we can
and um start to make arrays and so if
you look at the syntax we called the the
module or the package is called numpy
and we said we decided to name it MP
that means when we want to find a
function in the numpy library uh we use
this notation NP that's the Library
numpy dot that refers to something
within the numpy library and here we're
using the function array and this makes
an array with the numbers three four and
five as I had for X above and 497 for y
now when we add these
two uh which so NP is an abbreviation in
that case yes and we we could have
called this anything we could have
called it fu yeah if we called it Fu
we'd have to put Fu down here that's our
choice but NP is a standard abbreviation
for numpy in the in the literature so
now when we add these two arrays we get
more what we expect that's a relief yeah
yes uh so this array is the basic um
type of object for manipulating numbers
in in Python this is a one-dimensional
array because it's made from a list uh
well just one a one-dimensional
organization of uh numbers um there are
two-dimensional arrays threedimensional
arrays four-dimensional arrays um
matrices are simply two-dimensional
arrays uh with well with numbers in them
um you can have arrays with things that
aren't numb numbers but we don't have to
start with that okay um so here's an
example of a two-dimensional
array uh so we give it a list of lists
so if you note there's two square
brackets the first entry in the list is
the list one two the second is the is
the list 34 and this is going to make a
2 by two array or a 2 x two Matrix um
that we can use say to for multiplying
later okay now given an object in Python
the there are you know we may we'll want
to know some things about it so some
things we'll want to know is maybe to
find some of it the entries in the array
and we can do that with this square
bracket we'll see more in indexing later
but objects also have these thing called
attributes
so early it uses the same sort of dot
notation to reference something
associated with X so if I wanted to know
um the end dim tells us you know what
the dimension of the array is is it's a
two-dimensional array that shouldn't be
surprising um we can we can also ask
what kind of data is represented in the
array and these were integers if you saw
above we had put in integers so there
are various attributes um that are that
any any python object has many has
attributes and you can inspect them by
using this sort of reference here
okay so uh let's move on a little bit so
we might in of having integers we might
want to use floating points that's the
the representation of decimals in the
computer we can do that by adding an
argument um float when we call an array
and if you note I checked its dtype that
is what kind of data is collected other
attributes are its shape we won't dwell
on all the attributes there there are
many of
them okay so um besides attributes pyth
on objects also have methods uh so
here's my
array um it's just the list 1 2 3 and
four and I'm going to call this method
the sum method on X so what is a method
it's like an attribute in that it's
Associated to X but it's a function we
we see it's a function because it has
these round curly braces so not
surprisingly when we call the sum method
on X it Returns the sum of the values of
x so this should be
10 okay and well you can also compute
the sum of an array with a function
there's a function called sum in the M
nump library np. sum of X computes um
the sum
so whether a whether we use a method or
a function will often depend on the
context but um this this is just to know
that these are basic things that python
objects have attributes and methods um
and we can call functions on them as
well
okay moving on
um
so this next example talks about
reshaping an array which is which we
will not I I don't think it's worth
spending a lot of time on one thing I
want to show in this example is
something about how python uses
reference instead of value so I'm just
going to move on a little bit um to get
to this point so without having dwelt on
all the examples above we have we had an
original array X and then we made this
new array X reshape um X was an array of
um length six and we made it into a 2x3
Matrix so we can just check that down
here by plotting that so it's a 2x3
Matrix and what I what I want to show in
this quick example is something kind of
important about python is that um it
uses reference instead of value so this
x reshape it was
actually derived from X and actually has
the same data as X so let me just Excuse
me while I scroll up one little bit so
here this x reshape was found by calling
the reshape method of X so it's another
array it's not X it's something
different it has a different
shape
but when we so X started off as a
onedimensional array vshape you made it
a two dimensional array that's right so
that which is with the same numbers but
arranged in a two-dimensional array
that's
right um oh I'm sorry I see I tpe I put
a dot instead of a comma see even the
experts
make uh so this just to show that X as
Trevor had said is a is a
one-dimensional array of size six and X
reshape is 2 by3 the the one of the
pertinent things I want to show in this
is I'm going to change one of the
entries of X reshape so I'm going to
change here I've this notation here
square brackets is how you access
elements in the array and here I put 0
comma 0 um and that's actually the the
first the entry in the first row and
First Column for those of you who have
programmed another languages you might
wonder why I didn't put one comma one
for the first row and the first entry
and that's because well python is a
zerob based indexing uh compared to
other languages and I would say these
days I think zerob based indexing is is
quite is is more common c-based
languages use it um but any case Zero is
always the first it can be a bit
confusing for those who are used to one
being the first but like it was for me
yes yeah okay so I I'm sending the first
entry the entry the first row and First
Column of x3 shape to be five um so we
should expect when we look at XR shape
again that's what we'll do in the next
line um it's changed to five but X will
also have
changed so so after I've changed the
first entry of X reshape it has a five
in the first row in First Column but X
also has a five in its first entry and
that's because both X reshape and X they
still they refer to the same place in
the computer's memory when we change the
number sitting in that part of the
memory for X reshape we've also changed
it for x and this is just a useful thing
in when you start to see a language to
know whether it uses this reference
system or copy so using this reference
system is a way to be more efficient
sometimes um so that's just a a heads up
um that I wanted to to pass on when
talking about arrays so whenever Poss
possible num will make a will not copy
the array and it will make what is
called a new view of the array so it
viewed the same numbers as a 2x3 Matrix
at with X reshape as X viewed them as a
vector of length six another important
thing that we we'll use over and over in
the book is is we we'll Generate random
numbers so let's let's look a little bit
and we'll talk about the best practice
way to do that so that our results are
reproducible so the the numpy library
has ways to Generate random numbers this
will generate some random normal
variables um and uh one of the things
that's important in in writing something
going through a lab like this is to have
reproducible results so of course um the
numbers in a random number gener will
change from time to time if I rerun this
block the numbers have changed and
that's because they're random so we want
to be able to set a seed for the random
number generator so the best practice
way to do that currently is is is to set
a seed as follows we make a specific
random number generator using this
default RNG um and what we can what what
it allows us to do is have reproducible
results and now instead of using the
function np. random normal we use the
function rng. normal and there I said
function it's actually a method here but
these distinctions are kind of a fluid
so now we've created two random number
Jers with the same seed um and they're
going to give us exactly the same data
so that will be how we will have
reproducible results um throughout the
uh the
lab